the Florida man charged with
manslaughter for shooting and killing an
unarmed black man in a parking lot in
Clearwater is speaking out for the first
time in an interview with our Tampa
affiliate WTSP Michael Drake uh says he
was afraid for his life when he was
confronted by Marcus McLaughlin on July
19th surveillance video shows Drake
allegedly berating McLaughlin's
girlfriend for parking in a handicap
spot
McLaughlin shoved Rekha to the ground
draga then pulled out his gun and shot
McLaughlin authorities did not arrest
Rekha for nearly a month saying he was
protected by the state's Stand Your
Ground law the law allows a person to
use force to defend themselves without
having to retreat first Dracut believes
he followed the law I've had plenty of
time to think about it but as far as
changing anything its defense is it what
you're well I don't see I really did no
not off the top of my head
Rekha says the shooting was not racially
motivated he also apologized to
McLaughlin's family he remains in jail
on $100,000 bond